SPEAKER 1: I'm going to start
talking about Google Play
Instant.
That was announced at GDC.
And Google Play Instant is
all about [? means to ?]
[? gratification. ?] It's
about getting the user
in your experience
as fast as possible.
In today's world, you can think,
I send a message to my mom
and I tell her, try
out this new game.
She opens the link.
She goes to the Play Store.
She presses the Install button.
The game starts installing,
slowly, and slowly.
Then she forgets about the game.
She goes to the oven.
There was dinner cooking.
She completely forgets
about the game.
She never opens the game again.
Now here's the thing.
If you think about
the abandonment rate--
the number of people that
starts installing a game
and actually plays the game--
the number of people who don't
play the game at all-- forget
about installation--
is very, very high.
If you think about
the number, it's
probably higher than the number
you're thinking about now.
Now, we are taking
this problem here
at Google with
Google Play Instant.
And in this new world,
I send a link to my mom.
She opens the link.
And instead of going
to the Play Store,
she starts immediately into
the game-- in a few seconds,
the game starts running.
And it's downloading
in native application
with no installation whatsoever.
So there's no more
friction there.
Now my mom is playing.
She forgets about dinner.
And I don't have dinner.
It happened quite a
few times, actually.
The key points
here are, the code
that is being downloaded
for a Google Play Instant
application-- game in our
case-- is native code.
It's not JavaScript in
their virtual machine.
It's native code.
And it does have access
to almost everything
that a normal application
has access to.
And we're going to see examples.
Now Matt from Zynga
implemented Instant Game,
and is going to talk
about their experience.
MATT SAMET: All right.
So, hello.
My name is Matt Samet.
I'm a senior technical
manager in Zynga's Strategic
Partnerships Group,
which basically
means that I help manage the
relationships with our platform
and development
partners, such as Google.
And here's what I'll
be talking about today.
So [? Fran ?] gave
you a quick recap
of what the platform
is all about.
But I'll cover why
we're on the platform
and what really
excites us about it.
And then I'll show you a quick
look of each of the three
Instant games we made.
And then I'll kind of
cover how we made them
and go into a few of
the technical details.
And then I will talk about
some key takeaways and things
to remember when you're
building your own Instant games.
And there'll be some time at the
end, hopefully, for questions.
So this is basically why
we're on the platform.
This is what it's all about.
There's a huge potential
to boost your installs
for your game, and to then get
your game seen by many more
people who may not have
seen it, or who may not
get the opportunity to see it.
And you can sidestep some of
the drop offs that you see,
when you acquire users
on the Play Store.
For example, if you have
a really large game,
you get that prompt, if you're
not on Wi-Fi you may want
to avoid downloading
this game on cellular--
all those things, those
are friction points,
those are funnel drop offs.
So with Instant, you can
really sidestep those.
And also, if people
aren't ready to commit
to downloading your game
for whatever reason--
maybe they want to try it out.
Maybe they don't know what the
full experience is going to be.
You can give them a trial.
And in fact, you don't
really have to acquire users
from the Play Store at all.
And that's one of the
really exciting things
about this platform, is that
you can kind of creatively
distribute these games on
different channels that
were unavailable for mobile
game distribution, previously.
So our goals,
getting started, were
to build something that
allows us to really understand
what development and
publishing looks like
on this new platform.
And hopefully we'll see
the tangible benefits
of actually making these
products to our DAU
and installs.
So that was the main goal.
The way we do that
is we really focus
on getting the user into
the Instant experience
as quickly as possible.
And then we show them how fun
the game is, right up front.
And then when we
feel that they've
gotten a good sense of what the
full experience is going to be,
we try to get them to
install the full game
from within the Instant game.
So let's talk about
what we built.
We started Zynga
Solitaire, which
is a super simple
solitaire game,
written in Java
with Android Studio.
Pretty standard solitaire game.
Nothing too special.
So this was an obvious
choice because it
was a very simple
game, and we wanted
to get started with a simple use
case for learning the platform.
So for Google Play
Instant, we're
able to fit the entire game
into the Instant experience.
So you can play it instantly.
And if you want a new game,
we prompt you to install.
So, pretty straightforward.
And this was a single
developer, just me.
It took me about three
days to get started,
and about a week after that to
have it ready for publishing.
So then we wanted to expand a
bit with one of our top games,
Words With Friends 2.
So this is a very popular
social word tile game,
written in Java and
c++ with Cocos2d-x.
So for Instant, we took the
game's Solo Series Ladder,
which is the game's
single player experience,
and we made that the focus,
so that players can really
get a taste of the full game
and what it's all about just
by clicking Try Now.
And you play against bots.
And we drop you right into
the game board, right away.
And you experience the fun game
play as quickly as possible.
And once you beat a few
levels of the solo series,
you can install the full game.
And the Words With
Friends team had
two engineers working on
this for about a total
of four weeks.
So then we really wanted to
challenge ourselves and see
what can we do on the platform.
What's possible?
So CSR 2 is an immersive
3D street racing
game built in Unity.
It's got state of the
art graphics, relatively
demanding, high fidelity game.
And we have a lot of really
fine attention to detail.
We work directly with
the car manufacturers
to get extremely
detailed car models.
So the full game is
about 1.3 gigabytes,
so fairly significant
on the download size.
But with Instant, we can
ensure we get maximum reach
and get players excited
before committing
to that full download.
So what we did was, we
did a showroom experience.
And we're showcasing
a single car
from the latest downloadable
content available
in the full game.
And you can explore the car
in full graphic fidelity.
You can spin around the car.
You can scale it up and down.
It's actually interactive.
You can open and close
the doors and the hood
and generally see what you're
going to get in the full game,
as far as the fidelity goes.
We also added AR mode,
which is a feature
available in the full game.
It's powered by AR Core.
And this is great for getting
really up close and personal
with the cars, doing
some fun stuff.
Like, there's my Lamborghini
parked next to my other car.
I put a Lamborghini on my
desk inside, because why not?
So let's see how each
of these were done.
Go into depth here a little bit.
First, let's talk some
about the requirements
of being on the Google
Play Instant platform.
So the most significant
thing that you're
going to have to deal with is
that 10 meg initial APK limit.
It can also be the
hardest to overcome,
which is why it's so
important to focus
on the absolute core gameplay
experience that really captures
what the essence of the game is.
So you can download as much as
you want after the game starts
running, but the initial
APK that users download has
to be under 10 megs.
So, these experiences run
on Android L and above.
That's 5.0 and above.
If you use OpenGL ES for
any of your graphics,
and if you do 3D graphics,
if you use GL ES,
it has to be 2.0.
3.0 is not supported yet.
That thing on the lower left
is actually Push Notifications.
They are not available
on the platform.
So there's no obvious way
to reengage your users.
So that's why we kind
of focus on getting
the user into Instant,
and then as soon as they
get a sense for the
gameplay, we try
to drive them to install
as quickly as possible.
So you have a few other
things, like a reduced set
of permissions.
For example, you can't request
external storage permissions,
things like that.
You need to use HTTPS for
all of your network calls.
And there's a few Android
APIs that are not available--
things like getting persistent
IDs and stuff like that.
And finally, when
you build your game,
you need to use a relatively
recent version of Gradle
that supports the Instant
App structures and features.
So this is a little
bit about Solitaire.
You may or may not be familiar
with the diagram on the side,
but this comes from the Google
Instant Apps documentation.
Basically, you have
features which are basically
a unit of functionality or
game play in your game or app.
And then you have your
Instant App module,
which depends on features.
And you have your
regular app module.
So you have a unified
build that can actually
target both platforms,
Instant and installable.
So for Solitaire, we're actually
able to refactor the Android
Studio project into a simplified
version of this diagram.
Namely, we're able to
fit the entire game
into just the single base
feature, which is not typical.
Usually, you wouldn't
have your full game
available as an
Instant App, usually.
But for this one it turned out
to be so small that we could
put the entire thing in there.
So the game was already
relatively small.
It's just a standard
Solitaire game.
So we enabled asset minification
and a few other settings.
And it fit pretty much
right into 8 megabytes.
So not too much to
worry about there.
One of the challenges
that I had to overcome
when doing this game was
upgrading an older Gradle build
script--
actually, a set of older
Gradle build scripts,
to the later Gradle version.
And I hadn't had much experience
with Gradle before this.
And there is a fairly large
jump in required changes
between the two versions.
So just getting familiar with
all those changes was really
helpful in getting familiar
with the required things
you have to do to
make an Instant App.
And also it helped with
our other Instant Apps
that we did after Solitaire.
And then, when I
was ready to submit
to the alpha track
on the Play Console,
going through the process was
really helpful, because it
turns out, when you
submit an Instant App,
it will probably tell
you some of the things
that you might not
have done correctly.
For example, supporting
Android app links
and linking your
app to your website
that you own with a
digital asset links file.
So getting that whole process
understood really well
was really helpful as well.
And then Words With Friends
was actually relatively easy,
which kind of says a lot.
Most of the work was specific
to the game and to Zynga code.
Not too many dependencies on the
Instant App runtime or Android.
So that was good.
And we didn't really have
to optimize it that much--
you know, removing some
unneeded SDKs, things like that.
And when we focused on
the core experience, which
is that solo series, we
got to kind of remove
a whole bunch of other parts
of the game that contributed
a lot to the size, especially
with texture atlases and game
modes, things like that.
And when we removed
all those things,
that pretty much got us within
striking distance of the 10 meg
limit.
So when we started
working on CSR2,
this kind of summed up
what we were thinking.
Not an obvious path from
1.3 gigs down to 10 megs.
But the solution was pretty much
the same as for other games--
we wanted to refocus on really
the core of the game, what
makes the game fun, or the
essence of the full game.
And this image is
pretty accurate.
It turns out that we scaled
down the game quite extensively,
and we ripped out most of it.
So originally, what
we were going to do
was a playable race
from the tutorial level.
But we decided to pare it
down, because it's not just
about the race.
Actually, what makes it fun
is all the other things,
like collecting your cars,
customizing them, seeing them
in their extreme detail.
So a showroom can do that.
And it was within our grasp for
the initial attempt at this.
And that's kind of
what we focused on.
And we basically removed
absolutely everything else
from the game, which
was quite a lot.
And we had a lot of
fun doing it as well.
We had commit messages that
were like, now down to 700 megs.
And now down to 400 megs.
So we had some fun with it.
So a few other things that
we had to keep in mind.
The game relied pretty heavily
on Android expansion files.
These are so-called OBB files,
because, your APK can only
be 100 megs, I think, or
somewhere around there.
Obviously, the bulk of it had
to be in the expansion files.
And because this is all
about Instant downloads--
relatively instant--
you can't download several
hundred megabytes of data.
OBBs are not available
on the platform.
So, turns out that we needed
to completely re-architect
the way that the
game loaded assets,
because there's not an
expectation of the OBB file
being there anymore.
So it turns out, we rewrote
the asset loader to load things
locally from resources.
The game used GL ES3
to render the cars.
Specifically, it needed
a particular GL extension
that was more prevalent on
devices that supported GL ES3.
And given that the platform
only supports GL ES2,
this is something we
had to think about.
We never really got
around the issue,
just due to lack of time
and a few other things.
But this was mainly a prototype.
So, fortunately, we didn't
have to really worry about it.
When building the game, Unity
outputs a Gradle project.
This Gradle project has no
idea what an Instant App is.
So this is something I
believe is being worked on,
but don't quote me on it.
But for what we
had to do here, we
had to basically manually
modify the Gradle scripts,
add references to
all of the feature
targets, the
refactoring the modules.
This game was
relatively involved
because it used a lot of
third party libraries,
a lot of native libraries.
So all of that had to be
tied into the Gradle setup.
Let's talk about a few
things to keep in mind
when you're developing
your own Instant games.
So one of the most important
things to keep in mind
is to keep things focused
on the core of what
makes your game fun.
It really helps with
optimizing the size,
but it also ensures the user
is enjoying the experience
right from the get go.
I forgot where,
but somebody said
that there's a less than
10 second window from when
a user tries a brand new game
before they lose interest.
So if you don't capture
their excitement
within that 10 seconds, then
they might lose interest.
I'm not sure how
exactly true that is,
or how you can verify it.
But there is clearly
something there
that you need to optimize for.
So if your game loads
data at runtime,
it might be a good idea to show
the user something quickly,
to hide that load
in the background.
If it's not the first
level of gameplay,
then at least some
kind of loading bar
or something for the user
to see and engage with as
they're waiting.
And it's always a good idea
to test early and often,
especially on device
and especially
across both Android 7 and
Android 8, because the Instant
App runtime is actually
implemented differently
on each of those OS versions.
And you can have bugs on
one and not the other.
So it's important to
keep that in mind.
And submitting an early
build to the Play Console
under the internal
or alpha track
will really help, because it
will surface errors early.
You kind of want to
get those under wraps.
And you want to get them
fixed as quickly as possible,
because you don't want to wait
until your game is about to hit
production and there's
some weird error that
gets surfaced to you right
as you're trying to submit.
And it's always a good
idea to write your game
in a flexible way.
Ideally, you can
make it data driven.
This especially
applies if you're
working on a brand new game.
It really helps,
because it's easier
to restructure the app for
when you do an Instant game,
because it's usually pretty
different, product wise,
from the full thing.
And, in our experience,
several third party SDKs
were only partially
compatible with Instant Apps.
This is a situation
that's always improving.
And it's probably vastly
different from when we started.
But it's never a bad idea
to check your third party
dependencies.
And since nobody likes
writing duplicate code,
if you can share it
with your main app,
it's always a good idea.
You also get the
benefit of free access
to any updates made
to your main game.
They will just filter down
into the Instant game.
So that's pretty much all I had.
Thank you.
If you have any questions,
happy to answer.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for the talk.
Just wondering if you can,
or anyone from Google can,
share any stats on
how that improves
the install rate of funnel.
MATT SAMET: That is,
unfortunately, the only thing
I can't talk about.
I'm trying to think.
SPEAKER 1: I can say it's
significant for all the games
that were talked about.
It's not bad.
AUDIENCE: But you can actually
see the stats of installs
from the store directly, and
separate it from the ones
through Instant, right?
SPEAKER 1: Correct.
MATT SAMET: If you look at
Google's developer day keynote
presentation at GDC, I
believe they did talk
about that a little bit.
And they talked about, for
the early launch partners,
kind of what lift they all got.
SPEAKER 1: There's also going
to be any other talk [INAUDIBLE]
where they're going to
share more information.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You said
you stripped out
some of the bug
reporting architectures.
Are you still getting
some bug reporting?
Are you still getting metrics
on users in the instant run?
MATT SAMET: Yeah.
We left one in.
It turns out, there
was more than one.
Why?
I'm not sure.
AUDIENCE: And are you still
able to gather metrics
from within the Instant play?
MATT SAMET: Yeah.
These are standard.
They're pretty much
just like normal apps.
You can run all those libraries
and get the same data.
AUDIENCE: So my Samsung Galaxy
S8 doesn't show the Try Now.
Any idea why that might be?
MATT SAMET: For which game?
AUDIENCE: For Words
With Friends 2.
MATT SAMET: I think
I know why that is.
That's a bug that just
surfaced last week.
But it normally does.
AUDIENCE: So it might show
up in another week or so.
MATT SAMET: Yes.
If you actually send
yourself an email to the URL
that we used, to our games
page, for Words With Friends,
and you click on that link,
in, for example, your GMail app
or something, it will actually
launch the app that way
as well.
You don't need to be on the Play
Store to launch these things.
You can actually launch
them from anywhere
you can click a link.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I just wanted to answer
the question quickly.
Right now, Instant Game
doesn't work on the 8.0.0.
Your Galaxy S8 is probably
8.0.0 on the [? regression. ?]
So you need to wait
for an update to 8.1.
SPEAKER 1: Also make sure
that Instant Apps are enabled.
MATT SAMET: Which they should
be, by default, I think.
But it's always good to check.
AUDIENCE: So with your
Instant app with Unity,
did you actually
make a separate app,
because you'll be
sharing the game
code and that sort of stuff?
Because you were
talking stripping out
that many libraries.
Did you actually make
a separate app for it,
or did you do a subset of?
MATT SAMET: It's
an extreme subset.
It's basically
sharing the same code.
It's branched.
But it outputs like a
completely separate APK.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So you use a different build.
Because I do a lot of shared
build systems and that stuff.
So I use a separate
build flow for that.
Instant App with Unity?
MATT SAMET: Right.
In the game, we had an extremely
customized build script.
And we just kind of extended
that for the Instant App
target.
AUDIENCE: Sweet.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Just
trying to understand
the connection between
the Instant App
and the app you install later.
If you want to persist your save
game data from one to another,
what are the mechanisms there?
MATT SAMET: So on Android
8, it's automatic.
It actually shares the same
app container on the device.
So there's an API called
Show Install Prompt.
You call that.
And the user clicks Install.
And the full app gets
downloaded and installed.
And whatever user data you
stored in the Instant App
container will be
available to the main app,
just as if it was put
there by the game itself.
And on Android 7, I believe,
there is a migration API
that you can call.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.